[Musique]
[Musique] la
fédération des charmeurs de serpents de l'Inde
estime qu'il y en a environ huit cents
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
mille [
Applaudissements] [
Musique] le
charme de serpents est un
moyen de subsistance cruel et illégal brutal qui n'est pas
nécessaire il n'y a pas de place dans la civilisation
société
pour que les gens se promènent en attrapant des serpents
et en les prenant et en faisant
une sorte de spectacle de divertissement
avec un serpent
[Musique]
étranger étranger
il est également important de comprendre que
le venin
que les serpents venimeux ont comme des cobras,
etc.
ils sont très  protéine concentrée et
les serpents
ont besoin de cette protéine pour digérer leur nourriture
et si vous enlevez, c'est comme
enlever la bile de votre estomac, il ne
pourra pas manger ou digérer sa
nourriture,
évidemment le serpent va s'affaiblir,
ils obtiennent souvent un  infection de la bouche
et ils commencent à s'affaiblir
chaque jour
[Musique]
les serpents n'ont pas d'oreilles ils ne peuvent même pas
entendre
la musique que le charmeur de serpent
joue donc évidemment ils ne peuvent pas danser
le charmeur de serpent est assis devant le
serpent avec sa flûte et  bouge
constamment
ou il bouge son genou quand il est
assis accroupi en
dessous ou à côté du serpent et donc le
serpent
bouge simplement en regardant la
flûte ou le genou ou un objet de
mouvement qui
ressemble à une menace donc le serpent
n'est pas  danser
loin de là le serpent est terrifié et
tout ce qu'il veut faire est de s'échapper
[Musique]
le charmeur de serpents clouera la tête à
un arbre
utilisera une lame et l'entaillera autour du cou
puis
enlèvera toute la peau du
serpent vivant  comme un bas, vous pouvez
imaginer la douleur
et l'agonie atroces que le serpent traversera
lorsqu'il
souffrira quelque chose comme ça et
c'est la vilaine vérité
derrière le charme du serpent, donc des milliers et des
milliers de serpents
meurent chaque jour en tant que victimes du charme du serpent
[Musique]
cette loi rend illégal la chasse, la
capture, la possession ou la mise à mort de
tout animal, tout animal sauvage et les serpents
sont tous protégés,
un charmeur de serpents pourrait techniquement s'il
n'avait pas
de certificat de propriété délivré par le gardien en chef de
la faune de l'État
pourrait être puni d'un  peine de prison pouvant aller
jusqu'à sept ans
et il aurait une amende qu'il
devrait également payer au gouvernement
bien qu'officiellement illégale, la pratique est
encore courante,
en particulier dans les zones touristiques et les petits
villages [musicaux],
c'est une pratique qui a été dépassée il y a
longtemps,
elle est illégale en Inde et elle doit
vraiment s'arrêter
et certainement le tourisme et les gens qui
pensent que c'est  quelque chose de spécial
ne doit pas inciter ou récompenser cela
à la place, nous devrions encourager ces personnes
à adopter des moyens de subsistance alternatifs
et à abandonner le serpent qui vous charme